da schlägt das herz jedes star wars fans
für australischen wissenschaftlern ist
die konstruktion eines todesstern lesers
gelungen er bündelt die strahlen von
drei leser auf einen vierten strahl der
dadurch seine leistung fast verdoppeln
kann schon den 60er jahren wurde daran
von sowjetischen forschern geforscht
aber jetzt ist es gelungen aber warum
hat der tourbus ferngläser früher nicht
geklappt und funktioniert jetzt klick
zum sitzen
herzlich willkommen wir kennen die
entscheidenden szenen aus davos im
todesstern werden ein paar hebel
umgelegt und von schiefen sechs
laserstrahlen aus ihm auf einen punkt
und vereinen sich zu einem strahl der
dann den planeten alderaan zerstört die
heimat von prinzessin leia das ist ein
schlimmer moment in star wars 2 4 hat
sich eingebrannt in das kollektive
gedächtnis von millionen menschen
jetzt ist forschern genau dieses
szenario gelungen nicht auf dieser skala
sei hier werden keine planeten zerstört
wissenschaftler und physiker mckay von
der macquarie university sydney ist die
zusammenführung von 3 lesern auf einen
vierten strahlung der feuerstrahl wurde
dabei um 4,6 kilowatt auf knapp neun
kilowatt verstärkt gefördert werden die
forscher von der us airforce die
offensichtliche an der entwicklung von
laserwaffen interessiert ist der strahl
hätte damit schon das potenzial zur
waffe er kann auf diese weise bleche
durchschneiden allerdings existierte er
in diesem experiment so einigen
nanosekunden forschung dazu gab es schon
in den sechziger jahren in der
sowjetunion die allerdings an der hohen
hitzeentwicklung gescheitert sind die
forscher nutzten damals flüssigkeiten
und komprimierte gase war hatten sie
aber große schwierigkeiten mit der hitze
und gaben die forschung auf die
australischen forscher haben jetzt
diamanten zum transfer der laserstrahl
auf den vierten straße raymond bienen
kombination frank verwehrte mit den zwei
millimeter großen diamanten haben sie
das hitzeproblem gelöst hoch eine
diamanten leiten die wärme sehr gut ab
und werden inzwischen in hoher qualität
im labor hergestellt und sind damit auch
bezahlbar damit ist der weg frei für
festkörper leser die einigermaßen mobil
sind und eine
eure leistung haben als bisherige leser
dieser bauart bisher endete ihre
leistung bei einigen dutzend kilo war
jetzt konnten die forscher durch die
neue technik diese grenze deutlich nach
oben zu verschieben und bürger
leistungen von einigen 1000 kilowatt zu
erreichen einziger haken sind noch die
diamanten welche probleme wie bei höhere
leistungen verursachen ist noch
vollkommen unbekannt der weg zum laser
krieg ist also noch nicht frei und ich
persönlich hoffe dass wir auch nicht so
schnell realität dass wir jetzt jeden
tag gibt es hier ein neues richtung
science fiction video passt nicht wenn
er mir hier ein arm aufs auge durch
dafür
dort klicken und mir einen auf die
glocke gehen also bis dann bleib dran